benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
so che questo video più o meno l'hanno
già fatto tutti l'avrete già visto ma
ovviamente mancava la mia fantastica
versione sono sicura che ognuno di voi
si ritroverà in queste tipologie e
quindi partiamo subito ci vediamo alla
fine del video comode yama svedese che
devi super rapani la solitudine tra noi
[Musica]
un certo l'augurio di buone
adesso sì che ragioniamo
[Musica]
modo punto nero questo bellissimo e
perfetto parate noterai quasi per
ricordo quest'anno ciste maschiaccio non
vorrei adesso una bella stalker ata
generale del mio ex della sua nuova tipa
del tipo che mi piace e siamo a posto
letizia sta già con un'altra guarda sto
stronzo ne cambia una al giorno
l'ho vista due volte l'ho vista tre
volte l'ho vista sei volte l'ho vista
una volta sola quindi potrei rivederla
corri muoviti che poi ti uccide ma che
se cade dalle nuvole si sapeva che
tradivano sapevamo tutti quanti soltanto
tu non lo sapevi guarda che te non più
grosse ammazzo
[Musica]
cos'era
ho dieci sono i ladri
ma così veloce ma non viene così uffa
perché la voce ma quanta terra si mette
dimmiquando super mare di la casa pulita
è un'altra cosa
altro che comunque l'esame solo dal 24
iniziare a studiare
oggi non lo sapevi sì sì ma mai sono già
di sette mesi che di tra due mesi
partorisco ed un maschio e femmina 2
[Musica]
no amore non puoi capire ha detto che
sono sbarcato sul divano che più che su
proprio da dio
praticamente mi sono appena mangiata una
parmigiana addirittura più grossa
diversi insetti restringere un po
passata appena tirato il rutto che lasci
[Musica]
chiediamo spalle sistemare ecco dove era
il mio recchino preferito che sono belle
altro
ecco la crema si può risparmiare un po
di crema sulle ma ecco telefono si
cazzeggia sei proprio un cretino
no io invece sono a un concerto nel
backstage perché sono ricca del cantante
quindi per questo non senti il rumore
perché siamo pochi intimi
è un modo molto pray that se la sarà
bevuta fc purtroppo arrivati alla fine
del video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto e che vi siete ritrovati in
queste tipologie poi devi sapere con un
commento qui sotto
in quale di queste scene vi siete
ritrovati maggiormente e soprattutto se
non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al mio cane e cliccate sulla
samp ha nella vicina tassa d'iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che pubblicherò un nuovo video e
ricordatevi anche di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social instagram facebook ei
tic toc
io vi mando un bacione norme ci vediamo
al prossimo video ciao
[Musica]